today on our show Xing the men and get
even the Rose all I'm so much more on
brand-new fat man on Batman story right
now
so you know universe building is very
popular in the movies these days kids
now that Marvel has done it they're the
first ones that ever did it a view askew
successful
everybody wants the universe of course
DC Warner Brothers jumping on board with
their universe mm-hmm
this is a new one man but we've heard
echoes of this before and now it seems
like it's coming into fruition give us a
2-shot the Hasbro Cinematic Universe now
you're sitting there going what no what
do you mean what the here's here are the
players in the Hasbro universe that you
could cross over like avenge your eyes
the Hasbro universe ready shoot GI Joe
great all those GI Joe movies rom the
space night
[ __ ] yeah big favor from our childhood
all his stuff his face he had a huge
Marvel Comics run it's crazy Marvel
doesn't have this character but has
grown zhem because they owned the toy
mm-hmm like I bet you if Marvel could
get their hands on they would totally do
that he was so popular for them back in
the James Gunn loves ROM matches tolis
James Gunn want to use ROM and guardians
and he couldn't because this has
birthing you know that means James Gunn
gonna wind up directing watch AMRAAM
movie by me by [ __ ] the guy that made
guardians the galaxy yeah
I'd watch the guy make Gardens a galaxy
[ __ ] my wife I know it's untoward to say
but I'm saying that's how good he does
break my heart but I feel like goddamn
look at him and also Fillion will be
there here we go
ROM the space Knight yes visionaries :
Knights of the magical life so those
hologram figures and back in the day
okay there they are
but sure every one came with a little
hologram they had their own cartoon the
Hasbro universe as you're figuring out
each toy line had its own cartoon hmm
and these cartoons had massive
I mean maybe not visionary not so much
not so much that but you know their
cannabis everybody gets a mirror the
visionary universe gets destroyed in the
opening and that's what starts the
mystery right that's the plant that goes
down for good like we a sacrifice I
might like lose the visionaries
Holograms what does it add to that list
Liske
okay good add to that list micronauts
[ __ ] you've been sitting there
for years going when well my granades be
back they're coming back look at him
look at them all my granades were a big
part of my childhood even though I never
owned one and never at the time they
were there they were omnipresent man
always in a discount bin that became our
tour - guys micronauts their thing was
their spoken tiny yeah it's the
micronauts but they also had a very
successful comic book run I believe also
at Marvel they told he did this was all
part of that like weird Marvel like I
think his books for a while
GI Joe for a very long time my be maybe
even this book although for some reason
I remember this book being a DC title
maybe I'm incorrect mask
yeah which stood for something that I
mask was an acronym that stood for
I don't motorized the song oh my god man
mobile army strike a man ladies and
gentlemen yeah also knows ok they
spelled combat wrong like I remember
Chuck Norris used to have a TV show
called Chuck Norris karate commandos
well karate and commandos were both
spelled with K's and I'm like you are
really one K away from being an
uncomfortable show from that every week
Chuck and his wife brand secret with
their friends [ __ ] and Ben hey Tyrone
should we go fight some crime man I'm
cool right
good luck with your KKK crimes they
steal your shits again son the the
hazard we've gotta get you gotta bring
[ __ ] market the if they did pull you
in
yes to work on the Hasbro University
films mark you would not be alone you
wouldn't be sitting there going well
clearly they did some also I would be
like the worst writer in that room
that's the thing I don't know about that
because you're [ __ ] damn good writer
but but they pulled together pretty
[ __ ] impressive writers room for
these Hasbro there is a lot of thick
dick in this room you my dirty now if I
read you this list of names and said
they're all writing Marvel or DC movies
you'd be like well of course
mmm-hmm but I'm gonna read you this list
of names and I'm gonna remind you each
time that this is about the
micronauts movie nights of the magical
light nobody remembers ready for this
writers room game's gonna be overseen by
Akiva Goldsman won an Oscar won an Oscar
for a beautiful mine however also wrote
Batman and Robin so he was the he was
you can't believe a kin the 90s mmm-hmm
once my studio did like Warner Brothers
they loved him and he was like you too
bad maybe but he did Batman Forever and
Batman okay so that guy's got pedigree
okay fair enough
fell you right away go alright a smart
play if you're gonna do some superhero
movies a gold in those we get David Carr
you get the cubicles totally but but
Akiva Goldsman pulled together a writers
room that make your head spin ready for
this
yes Pulitzer prize-winning novelist even
Michael Chabon Michael Chabon is in a
writers room for micronauts as
lin-manuel Miranda stalls the world has
turned upside down I don't know how the
[ __ ] this happened but yes the
Adventures of Kavalier and clay
amongst other things amongst other
things and spider-man too but you know
yeah and that's the thing though he is
like he he's a comics guy he likes calm
he is he wrote The Escapist for Dark
Horse for a while and I think he does
back up
I'm Casanova yeah cuz he just loves
[ __ ] Casanova medium yeah light so
you got Michael Chabon yeah Brian Kavon
never heard of that guy where is he from
I don't know he comes from the world of
[ __ ] comics and stuff like that one
of them self up cuz he's done lost under
the dome he's got some of these comics
guys there has to be when I was kid even
if all he did was why the last man it
would still be the huge [ __ ] get
Brian cables man and now I'm saga who
manifestly doesn't need to do anything
but make saga
what does have you reading so good
really it's really good Ozzy you're not
into Matt's
let's talk about comics for a minute
what is it it is it is ultimately a love
story about a boy a girl one of which is
kind of an angel one of which is a bit
of a demon but they live in an alien
planet and they get together and they
have a kid and it's all about them
raising this child between this sort of
Romeo and Juliet style fight between the
Montagues and the Capulets but that's
spacefaring and it's [ __ ] bananas it
is so fundamentally a comic book it
cannot be anything but a comic book
because there's like talking cats who
always tell the truth and there's crazy
royalty that have TV foreheads and it's
just it's bananas in the best possible
way when can we expect the feature film
according to this particular gathering
if anything is possible
visionaries Knights of the magical light
can be a movie then so can saga Nicole
Pearlman who was a co-writer and
guarding the galaxy she's in the writers
room as well and Joe Robert Cole who
wrote the Black Panther movie yep as
well as the People vs OJ Simpson which I
think a few people watch yes apparently
it's very not bad
stunning phrase yeah it's very not bad
mark but I mean the that's [ __ ] nuts
that sounds like a joke like Michael
Chabon Brian cave on the Coleman Joe
Robert Cole walk into a bar yeah I mean
it's as if you got like Kobe Bryant
Magic Johnson Michael Jordan Shaquille
O'Neal and Scottie Pippen to play
miniature golf I don't
to sports but even I understand that now
that's crazy particularly a miniature
golf part yeah that's that's the world
we live in I know we say that a lot on
the show of it like the Hasbro Cinematic
Universe coming your way if you ever as
a child sat in front of the TV and bit
like not now mom mask is on like Matt
our producer like Matt key your dais we
come every Wednesday comes that's what
we learn in this world man you like
something for a minute trust me sooner
or later somebody's gonna be like it has
a universe now there it is man or should
we mention like there's one you know
what before we go out yeah yeah yeah
that's almost there we'll finish it up
Game of Thrones yes
[ __ ] debuted strong yes strong the
ending was like creepy shining
Melisandre looking like God The Shining
woman yeah it's like oh she's really not
ha that's crazy that's good it's kind of
nice way there in the episode too cuz I
was like I was looking for a Big Bang
ending but that's [ __ ] yeah just sort of
alter the reality and it just shows you
her power in advance of you know if she
don't [ __ ] bring Jon Snow back from
the dead I quit this show I'm watching
the show until she [ __ ] brings done
then I'll keep watching but but yeah
that was that was dope there's something
my favorite moment what's her name the
tall and if to earth bran of ptarth
saving Sansa and Theon cried and I
screamed at the TV I was like yes [ __ ]
I forgot the if she was out in the woods
she just killed homeboy [ __ ] I was
that was my moment like I saw that I'm
like holy [ __ ] finally bring it and
then she did the [ __ ] meal and the
whole like when to go the off back and
forth and then just like yes I was
[ __ ] so good then there was a scene
with the Dothraki that I was almost
convinced that I wrote
like ok of the five good things in life
you know if I'll get a prettier seeing a
woman [ __ ] is one of them but uh what
if I was nice seeing the Dothraki again
was dope that they were like you were
called Drago's wife like you know your
time no good but you're going to a
[ __ ] monster that was dope
what else did I really like we're about
to see seriously [ __ ] go off mm-hmm
as she finally she realized we saw at
the end of last episode spoilers that
she lost our seller marsala
but then she you know is so
heartbreaking where she's down the ships
come in from Dorne and she they have to
[ __ ] like getting spit on and I've
[ __ ] I throw our airship long naked and
shame with the [ __ ] lady with the
balance [ __ ]
she's like finally my kids home yes
[ __ ] she sees Marcel is the one good
thing they ever did
yes that was the yeah and it was there
in the after thing you watch the thing
like afterwards and usually they talked
to Benioff him as it Weiss yeah and you
know they were like look she's you know
she even says in show she's like you
know is the one thing that kept me made
me think that I wasn't a monster I could
produce something that good and stuff
and their point about Circe's they don't
players like the ultimate evil
she just got her own [ __ ] agenda and
there's one thing you can never take
from her she loves her [ __ ] children
but she invoked that curse from that
like one opening episode one of the
other seasons Brigitte like you'll have
three children and the [ __ ] died [ __ ]
we're getting someplace where she's like
you know she's lost it all nothing less
to lose and they're gonna take on the
[ __ ] church which looks dope holy war
on that show I'm so [ __ ] all for ya
good way to start the season
yes like setting the table in such a
great way and with where the tasting me
I'll not even like and also all [ __ ] I
love wasn't Amster Devoe's mmm-hmm the
guy was missing fingers and [ __ ] like
that but he's like the most pragmatic
practical had a good guy on that [ __ ]
show if they kill him
he's my Darryl I ride man will not be
touched he's already lost too much of
those [ __ ] fingers that bitch-ass
king that [ __ ] Brienne took down and
[ __ ] like that
but if he goes I go I [ __ ] love that
guy sit CT remonster yeah really if
Tyrion goes I'm
I'd still watch right say that wasn't
much about secret attacks cuz I'm like
have I gotta do the [ __ ] without Tyrion
and if they were ballsy enough to be
like oh we can like think about it dude
like you watch season 1 and the end was
his name [ __ ] Ned Stark when they
kill their main character you're like
what the [ __ ] are we gonna do nobody
thinks about Ned Stark no more man yeah
that's true nobody it's like a bar
question like which guy dies and
everything Oh Sean Bean and then you're
moving the [ __ ] on but yeah it's it's
it's crazy man they could make you
forget Tyrion I feel like it Ned Stark
Tyrion Arya and I can't kill Arya I
can't kill no you can't kill Ari because
it's kind of like a lot of it is her
journey yeah
Tyrion and Daenerys that's that's now
you're Trinity like if they kill yeah
any of them we have a problem Game of
Thrones we have a problem you and I
problem he's generally a pretty peaceful
guy don't get him all [ __ ] pissed and
the last song about is the new x-men
trailers that just drop the dough just
yesterday I think it did looks great
like more of the same give me the movie
at this yeah I will sound like that one
shot where he's holding down [ __ ]
Charles and it gets big that's [ __ ]
dope I don't think they do big enough in
movies but I hear I'm gonna have that
rectified see yeah right it's gonna
wreck your rectify seems like there's a
lot of bigness coming in movies I like
that but that's cool the first time I
saw in the trailer some he's getting
[ __ ] huge in the mansion I just sort
of wished that they hadn't given away
that thing they give away at the end of
the trailer I did not know that that was
something to give I thought that was
assumed that that mmm that comes part
and parcel in there the posters and none
of the material so far did we know that
he was bad and did anybody say he was
caster nope they kept that under wraps
which flight like just give me a thing I
didn't know was gonna happen
yeah I got everybody excited yeah that's
I didn't quite understand what the
exciting I was excited just like me as
well Verne you better be there but
apparently he was not promised you know
that's what the big deal is right Andy
there's a safe something save something
for me save something for the guys who
show up and this is a takes place in the
80s this moment so this could be Weapon
X Wolverine it could be where
this was the one you see him for the
first leg in that shot at the end of the
trail of food when you see those it
could be wet him out the water and share
me but I'm being badass there we got
Matt what do you know you heard here
first folks Metanoia
yeah so then yeah it might be close
Matt's saying that last time we saw
Wolverine in movies had bone claws now
we're seeing a metal claws so if they
were following the last continuity it
would still be bone claws the fact that
we're seeing metal claws does point to
Weapon X could be cool didn't they do
weapon action 1 The Wolverine movies
well they did a version it was like
x-men 2 we sound like alkali lake and
all that [ __ ] but didn't they ever do it
in the they ever do it in one of the
Wolverine solo movies or anything yeah
so just just flashbacks and x-men 2 for
my money I think x-men 2 is my favorite
x-men movie still it's really strong the
opening with Nightcrawler banding
through the White House is fantastic and
you've got to give credit they did this
years before Marvel was even near the
canvas at this point but yeah I like the
x-men movie but the third act that
[ __ ] takes place in a gift shop like
it looks like they ran out of money
Superboy don't like just knock over some
[ __ ] Statue of Liberty trinkets it's
all fine second one now man they look
good to money Germans you see it it's
like on the [ __ ] screen so good yeah
and then the problem with x-men 3 is
that it wasn't Dark Phoenix it's close
like most with a Dark Phoenix II thing
right is standing around for some people
like do a boob man what's his name
directed they don't like Brett Ratner
yeah look I do a good job I like that
movie a lot right now it lost
credibility on the internet look for
food look excellent
I did find I think it's watchable and
I've watched it again fairly recent yet
no one is [ __ ] logical I Zak Penn who
wrote x-men 3 was created alphas the
show that I wrote for
and you know you said Liz I know we get
a lot of [ __ ] for that thing but if you
think about that movie I told you the
things that happened in us remember when
that happened yeah that was kind of cool
that happen it's not so bad yeah
and when magneto breaks the mystique out
of that truck yeah that's pretty cool
like there's more that's cool in that
movie then you remember it's like yes
it's a problem that Frankie Jackson
stands there for 45 minutes in the woods
just waiting for something happens it's
doing that stereo it's like yeah I'm not
saying there's not problems with it but
come on isn't it dope when she's [ __ ]
like when Wolverine has to get to her
and he's caught and he's breaking down
and regenerating Jake and then ask the
spoilers just [ __ ] take her out
that's good man that's good flesh ride
singer and [ __ ] like that
neither was x-men first class and that's
also a good flick that may be my second
favorite action flick I think I mean if
you don't count Deadpool I think it
would go x-men 2 for me and then x-men
first class that's include Deadpool
Deadpool
then x-men you like it as much as I
think that the first x-men doesn't quite
work all the time so balls to open that
movie in a concentration camp yeah like
by the way here's our big superhero play
Nazis and children and dance and by the
second one they're like the whole
thing's an allegory for being gay near
the scene where they're just like have
you tried not like you know yeah this
ballsy those Rossi movies they were
trying to do something that like now
people take for granted all they have to
do that in a comic book movie yes you
play real world stakes and blah blah
they were onto that in advance and
remember they didn't know what they had
so much so they montessori you were
working aw at the time yeah they didn't
test screen that movie nope like we do
for critics then show anybody that movie
just came out
that's no Fox was expecting like Billy's
no like this is gonna die yes you don't
look at big business it like probably
say Fox over the years couple times
because no he says print money off those
x-men they wouldn't give it back to
Marvel now the x-men The Simpsons was
what kept Fox aloft for a very long
while so while the Star Wars yeah that
was all his he got to keep most of that
money they got a distribution for you
for the second two Star Wars I think
they split but like his deal was like I
own Empire
I own jelly so they got a distribution
fee but he was like he had that little
stick at the table in Vegas where you
know what the the bedsheets your kid is
here that belongs to me and then he and
her dolls of God I do was smart I don't
know if he had helped or somebody
advising him or he's just smart enough
to be like I think kids will like the
toys toys I'm as much as the movies were
fun and great he created mythology those
toys that's that turned him into Solomon
King Solomon and scrooge mcduck and
smile all at once toys and sequels like
that's what he kept he had all the money
dude at one point he was the 1% was mine
I bought San Francisco Marin County
belongs to me you got any kid new he's
got a [ __ ] he's got thousands of
acres and hills of Marin County you
don't buy that on the cheap nope you buy
that because you're like you know what
bought this next hundred acres with my
GED eight figures just though no like
[ __ ] Disney and they're like you know
how much coke they sell in the morning
here
that's an IG eight moment for me AI g88
[ __ ] bought my gonna state that the
lamest robotic bounty hunter like lower
than Bosque welcome to under who's ranch
why can't we be as smart there it is
folks all the news that fits a print in
a mere hour and 10 minutes longer and
longer but cheers to all of you who I
see on Twitter and Facebook and on the
feedback here in the show that say I'll
watch this for three hours like just
keep [ __ ] doing it that's really sweet
and we'll get there this intermission in
the middle where we play like a refrain
from a lovely music it's true we'll put
on some music and go out get some corn
in the bathroom come back and resume fat
man on Batman's and then folks thanks
for hanging out with this man that's all
the news come back next week and we'll
next episode rather not even don't wait
a week come on accept
and we're gonna share something really
cool tea probably the civil review mmm
possibly perhaps you might yeah there it
is folks for fat man about nom Kevin
Smith Mark Barnard
tune in next time same fat time same fat
channel SModcast comma war youtube.com
slash Kevin Smith
a man's you like hearing us review Civil
War when that's fun yeah you want to
hear some of our other reviews click
down below take you to the review of
Batman V Superman and the Star Wars film
and Deadpool we review a lot of things
because we like things yeah
and talking about them mmm and I we like
looking back at having seen them up with
people were people persons reviewing
things but we like movies more yes not
people people are the worst they're holy
babe